you're watching swype coming up on this
week's show from paintbrush to pixel
when old gaming meets new millennial
shopping I get hands-on with a new way
to try before you buy and ever feel like
you're being phoned hello and welcome to
swipe this week from the studio's of
Creative Assembly a British video games
maker that's been releasing title since
the 80s and now they're bringing one of
tabletop gaming biggest franchises to
the virtual world and it's not the first
time that traditional and digital gaming
and worked in tandem here's Chris
suiting up for battle it might not look
like it but this is how you become an
orc it's part of the motion capture
process used to create characters in a
new video game all the markers that we
put on your body are relative to the
joints in your body and the cameras that
you see around you here will three of
them at a time will capture each one of
those markers in 3d space the wireframe
model shows my movement and then layers
are added so the designers can turn me
into any character they want maybe not
the scariest talk hopefully the finished
product is a bit more fearsome than I am
the title this studio is working on is
based on the popular table top strategy
game Warhammer in that players assemble
and paint an army of figurines pitting
them against each other in turn-based
battles how we control the animation and
much like the real life painting process
the team at Creative Assembly refine the
crude models created in the motion
capture studio from an animation point
of view a lot of those models look good
as a model if they move well it's a
different story for example we have a
lot of characters with huge head pieces
or flags or massive shoulder pads so so
we raise this arm and suddenly he's got
spikes going through his head so so
while it would look good as a miniature
it might not look quite as good in
motion there shall fall the finishing
touch sees voice actors add speech
to the characters bringing them to life
on the battlefield the full might of
chaos is arrayed against your blood
ravens it's not the first time tabletop
gaming has featured in the virtual world
the dawn of war series seen here is
based on a futuristic Warhammer spin on
diversifying into video games is a
massive marketing opportunity tabletop
companies getting involved with video
games opens up an entirely new audience
to them they used to view them as frets
used to think that people are going to
play video games instead of playing with
their toys or with their board games but
actually what you're finding is that
there's an entirely different generation
of digital generation of younger
generation of people that are
discovering things like warhammer
through the video games first and then
going over to the toys there's
definitely a crossover between these two
audiences in these two markets and
similar companies have taken advantage
of this appeal Lego almost went bankrupt
in the early 2000s but expanding into
the video game market helped it turn its
fortunes around today it's the second
largest toy company in the world so
video games and traditional games have
lots in common but while they both serve
the same audience there's no need for
them to go to war over customers Chris
Cregan Sky News now still the gum I get
to go shopping in the future but first
here's a roundup of some of this week's
tech news it's being touted as a selfie
stick with wings the hover camera uses
facial recognition to follow you as you
move around taking photos and 4k video
it can also be controlled through a
smartphone and the makers beijing-based
00 robotic set can fit inside your purse
crutches just got a facelift team in the
US have designed ones with shock
absorbing feet and arm cradles that take
pressure off your hands and wrists a
range of attachments for different
surfaces are also set to come soon
and while we're focusing on movement
take a look at X sense it's a wearable
with sensors that capture the sounds of
your muscles contracting your heart
beating and blood flowing so that you
can do things like play instruments and
video games and do digital drawings with
your movements and two students from the
University of Washington have created a
pair of gloves that turn sign language
into speech my name is Thomas naveed is
odee and Thomas Breyer won a
ten-thousand-dollar prize for this
wearable device it records hand
movements before transmitting the data
wirelessly to a computer that works out
what's being said and read the words
aloud who said farming was hard work
stay with us for our games review now
we've heard it all before the way we
shop is changing more and more of us at
buying things online but what if you
prefer to actually go to a physical
store well it turns out that set to
change too as I've been finding out till
here we are outside what looks like a
normal store but it is a shop of the
future my right is as a matter of fact a
mannequin is chugging to me the Monica's
going to have so listen it is
vegan so it's alerting me that when I
walk by and if I on my phone so
basically it's saying hello tail would
you like to see some of these products
which actually like to buy them I can
find out more
and if I wanted to buy it it's just a
click but the i was walking half is
silver and there's a nice guy in the
window I'm going to stop and look at it
I don't need an alert to tell me to talk
can you imagine if while you're admiring
the sphere it's prompting you to buy
maybe they're actually giving you a
coupon in but who has time to stop in
the stream and buy you do you have time
to remember this skirt and go home and
log on it then buy it it's immersive
that's right then it now so Jill we've
now come inside the showroom of the
future and you're going to try and sell
me a car yeah the car is not here so
you're going to buy a car by interacting
with this tablet this just looks like a
car website I know but this is different
so let me have you give it a go I
thought am I having a go out ok so now
touch the door
oh okay now pretend you're getting into
the car Wow am I actually going to get
in it's right there you go now you can
do some fun things all right you try out
some of the things on the dash so it's a
real try before you buy I can sit any
driver feeling okay let's work what can
I touch all these buttons work you can
try turning on the engine being around
the steering a little bit oh okay like
an Indian yeah there you go you can
actually turn on the windshield wipers
so do you think Carl retailers will
adopt this kind of technology so we
believe in partnership with Google that
accenture we can actually do some of
this technology award yeah some of this
cool technology to give it more of a fun
immersive feel is very clever it's sadly
very interactive but I love the smell of
a new car I'm not going to get that here
ry potentially there's other things that
you could be immersed in as well so
maybe all of your senses aren't going
crazy but maybe the touch in the feel of
the car and moving things around you can
actually feel like you're there I know
but I I just don't know whether that
really feels like I'm in a car it looks
like it but I don't feel like I'm really
touching this may be part of the selling
experience has changed
what is the dash look like because it
can have every time in the showroom so
maybe you're seeing just what could be
different to a great salesman vigil
recognize this guy he's part of the
inspiration for the video game you saw
in Chris's piece earlier but now it's
time for some more modern warfare here's
Gavin with this week's games review
remember Panzer General or battle aisle
from the 90s and it have you ever
wondered what would that turn based
strategy game be like in modern times
well that's what the creators of this
game thought as well and came up with a
brilliant solid idea problem is none of
the software publishers they went to or
it was a good idea but they didn't let
their dream die they started a
Kickstarter campaign now this is a real
success story of Kickstarter they tapped
into a fan base and through that they
were able to fund the whole project
including development it's basically
based in a world where war has torn it
apart and you need to start again from
scratch there are single player mode
multiplayer modes of course the good
thing is back in the 90s you didn't have
the ability to be able to play online in
multiplayer which of course you are able
to do in this eclipse is the second of
four DLC packs to come out for call of
duty black ops 3 this year now obviously
don't need t about the game it was one
of the biggest hemming games of last
year what I do need to tell you about is
this new pack which has come out
recently there are four brand new maps
to explore their spire which is probably
my most favorite this is like a
futuristic suborbital airport in the
cloud knock out which is a stage for a
kung-fu tournament so this looks a very
martial arts ii and oriental you've also
got ripped as well which is a futuristic
military base and virg which is a
reimagine a shin of the classic of band
life
professional farmer 2017 now in a games
review section on a TV show you may not
think you would hear of a game about
agriculture but think about it in the UK
it's a huge business it is very very
realistic the graphics are amazing the
equipment and the vehicles you use our
actual real vehicles and real equipment
that the farmers would use the scenarios
are the same so if you've ever fancied
running your own file might harvesting
crops or sensory animals but don't want
to get up at 5am in the morning or smell
of cows poo this could be the game for
you well that's it for this week take a
look at Sky News on mobile tablet catch
up and sky cue for all the latest tech
stories throughout the week and we'll
see you again next time bye-bye
you